sophie brochu va quitter son poste de
pdg d'énergie autrefois gaz métro le 30
décembre à la tête de la société depuis
12 ans se fit brochu estime qu'il est
temps de laisser une autre personne à
porter un regard nouveau sur
l'entreprise sophie brochu s'est jointe
à énergie en 1997 à titre de
vice-présidente elle à diversifier
l'offre de cette entreprise au fil du
temps à la faveur d énergie hydraulique
éolienne et solaire
sophie brochu sera remplacé par l'actuel
chef de la direction financière
d'énergie re éric lachance regard sur le
travail le leadership de sophie brochet
avec michel nadeau qui est directeur
général de l'institut sur la gouvernance
chez nadeau bonsoir c'est quand même une
personne importante dans le milieu des
affaires de montréal du québec c'est une
gestionnaire remarque et qu'est ce qu'on
doit interpréter de ce départ ben je
pense que madame brochu a été une
excellente gestionnaires comme
présidente de gaz métro elle n'a pas
fait d'erreur et c'est bien assurer le
développement de green mountain au
gouvernement vous savez gaz métro et est
responsable de l'électricité et du gaz
au gouvernement on sait également un
petit peu diversifiée dans l'éolien avec
la seigneurie de beaupré avec une
acquisition aux états unis il ya pas eu
de problèmes avec les relations de
travail avec la régie de l'énergie mais
voilà madame brochu est une personne
n'est dans les hydrocarbures elles
étaient autres a autrefois à la soquip
société québécoise d'initiatives
pétrolières de 87 à 90 avant gaz métro
la dalle est à gaz métro depuis 23 ans
dont trente trois ans dans le monde des
hydrocarbures et là ils la caisse de
dépôt qui contrôle de l'asthme est trop
l'actionnaire de référence celui qui
jusqu'ici est les commandes
c'est la caisse de dépôt en la caisse
des dépôts s'est probablement dit là
faut passer une autre une autre étape
la faute et laisser le gaz naturel faut
délaisser donc choses aller vers les
eaux lienne d'aller vers des
acquisitions à l'extérieur mais il faut
avoir une stratégie différente
et là évidemment on est allé chercher
quelqu'un qui a fait que depuis vingt et
un ans et à laquelle je sauve les deux
dernières années et à laquelle soient
faits des acquisitions beaucoup en
europe donc c'est plus simple
ancien qui va s'occuper las de voir
comment on va pas se faire énergie re
passer à une autre étape
les énergies nouvelles la
diversification géographique aux états
unis donc mais le distributeur de gaz
naturel au québec là que ce qu'incarnait
beaucoup madame brochu on s'est dit pour
tourner la page à la autre chose mais
c'est elle qui a amené énergie oui et
qui nous a expliqué d'ailleurs lorsque
nous donnaient des entrevues là dessus
parce qu'elle nous a donné des entrevues
à plusieurs reprises notamment à
vocation leader où elle parlait d'
antoine ayoub comme étant son professeur
de référence dans les années 80 qui
était vraiment un maître à penser dans
le secteur de l'énergie le pétrole etc
et elle nous a aussi donné des entrevues
dans les dernières années où ai parlé
d'énergie de cette transformation
fallait s'ouvrir à d'autres types
d'énergie
pourquoi elle n'incarne aurait pas ce
changement lorsque ça fait 12 ans et le
bienfait le pot fait d'erreur encore une
fois je pense que c'est une personne à
qui on ne peut rien reprocher son
jugement sa performance lieu tout petit
débat bécancour des réserves de stockage
de gaz naturel de ces minuscules
au total elle fait un bon travail mais
la caisse s'est probablement dit il faut
passer à autre chose pour passer à
réinventer énergie sur une nouvelle base
ne qui neutre en carbone sur une
identité nouvelle qui ne sera plus celle
de la distribution dont visage naturel
ce n'était pas son choix selon vous e
peut-être qu'elle aurait souhaité
incarner cette possibilité là mais je
pense qu'après 23 ans au sein de
l'entreprise la direction de la caisse
et surtout conseil d'administration a
décidé que ce serait peut-être bon de
trouver quelqu'un qui va donner une
perspective différente mais madame
brochu c'était le gaz naturel
alors que là maintenant il faut de
l'énergie ce toutes ses formes
on est au québec innergex et boralex
deux entreprises où la caisse de dépôt
est un gros actionnaire
est ce qu'un jour gains énergie re ne va
pas se rapprocher d'énergie que c'est
boralex c'est un pari que je serai dans
un discours au cercle canadien en
février 2010 est elle
exprimé son inquiétude devant la montée
des inégalités dans la société
elle va lancer un cri du coeur à ce
moment là pour que les entreprises
assument davantage de leadership sur la
question des inégalités
elle avait parlé d'un capitalisme plus
doux plus humain se fait-il que
l'entreprise qu'elle dirige ne répondent
plus nécessairement à ses idéaux ou à sa
vision de la société gl à elle donné je
vois ce qu'elle fait dans le quartier
hochelaga-maisonneuve où c'est ça et
alors qu'ils aident beaucoup n'auraient
s'appelle dans la rue je crois en une
ruelle de l'avenir c'est ça gaz métro et
d'un centre sud à la limite avec
hochelaga maisonneuve et ruelle de
l'avenir c'est vraiment pour contrer le
décrochage que cet homme là qu'on fait
on devra donc il faut indexer du très
bon travail est là mais encore une fois
je pense que la vision n'a pas madame
rochât a évolué et a changé sa vision
d'entreprise ce n'est plus travailler
juste pour les actionnaires mais là je
pense qu'encore une fois cette vision là
elle est très bien on n'a rien à lui
reprocher mais c'est une question
maintenant ça va être une vision plus
financière de la compagnie telus
diversification internationale faire
autre chose mais tranquillement oublier
le gaz naturel aller dans d'autres
domaines
et là monsieur lachance éric lachance
arrivent d'europe et étale en europe un
sujet sur beaucoup de conseils
d'administration et c'est probablement
quelqu'un qui peut être un peu mieux
préparés cas pas tout de 30 ans
d'hydrocarbures dans le corps et qui va
probablement mettre en place cette
nouvelle stratégie qui voulut par la
caisse de dépôt maintenant que la caisse
soit privatisé la compagnie la compagnie
était privatisé les de l'été dernier il
ya plus d'action dans ses démarches et
vous qui connaissez bien le monde des
affaires toutes les arcanes elle va ou
madame brochu moi je pense que mme
brosseau a deux choix elle pourrait
devenir président d'un autre organisme
d'une autre entreprise où elle pourrait
devenir une administratrice de sociétés
de carrière vous savez qu'à deux
semblent elles déjà un ou deux gros
conseil à 200 mille dollars par année en
moyenne deux ou trois autres conseils ça
fait 6 l
ces six à huit cent mille dollars et la
voix près
cinquante jours de travail wes popir bce
bm au cjc déjà trois gros conseil c'est
je pense qu'avec ce à chaque fois il y
aura quelque chose pour mettre au pied
de l'arbre noël elle est l hiver
prochain
merci michel nadeau venir c'est beaucoup